en este vídeo vamos a ver como colocar
las tapas de abajo o las ruedas y las
llantas o los anillos o las ruedas ya
tienen una perforación en el centro pero
vemos que la perforación es muy pequeña
por lo que tomamos nuestro
destornillador para agrandar un poco
estas perforaciones es muy importante no
agrandar demasiado estas perforaciones
ya que de hacerlo así las ruedas
quedarán flojas y podrían salirse de los
ejes vamos a empujar las para colocarlas
y nos debe costar trabajo ponerlas algo
que quiero comentar es que en este vídeo
hice las cosas sin orden
es importante poner los anillos en las
ruedas antes de colocarlas en este vídeo
lo hice al revés por lo que me costó más
trabajo así que primero pongan los
anillos en las ruedas y después coloquen
las ruedas en el eje en un momento
veremos cómo conectar los anillos o lo
que estoy haciendo aquí es ver si la
rueda gira bien pueden ver que se
bambolea un poco cuando la giro así que
tengo que seguir ajustando
hasta que se mueva sin problemas ahora
hacemos lo mismo del otro lado empujamos
la tapa con fuerza y entro ya que está
en su lugar debemos asegurarnos que gira
sin problemas y no se bambolea ya que
están bien puestas tomamos la pistola de
silicon caliente y ponemos una gota
grande que cubra lo que sobresale del
eje sostenemos esto hacia arriba y
esperamos que se seque después hacemos
lo mismo del otro lado asegúrense de no
voltear el robot hasta que se haya
enfriado el silicon de cada lado le
tomará dos o tres minutos para que el
silicon pase de ser transparente a verse
lechoso ahora vamos a conectar los
anillos o las llantas en nuestras tapas
y como les comenté hace un momento
colocar los anillos es mucho más
sencillo cuando las tapas no están
colocadas así que no lo hagan como lo
hice yo aquí aquí me estoy asegurando de
que ya seco bien el silicón caliente y
voy a tratar de estirar el anillo para
colocarlo en la rueda está muy ajusta
lo que es bueno porque no estas llantas
no se van a caer y nos van a dar un buen
agarre al suelo pueden ver que no es
fácil poner el anillo más cuando tenemos
todo el robot conectado si las tapas
están sobre la mesa es más fácil poner
el anillo porque lo podemos empujar
apoyándonos en la mesa
vaya ya tenemos una llanta en su lugar
pondremos la llanta del otro lado de la
misma forma nos aseguramos de que el
anillo quede derecho y todo gire bien y
ya que coloquemos la otra llanta vamos a
poner todo en la mesa y rodar lo hacia
adelante y hacia atrás una y otra vez
para ver que se mueva con suavidad y que
nada esté rozando las ruedas se debe
mover sin problemas y ya estamos listos
para el siguiente paso